[Music]
in responsible drunk driver news that
doesn't make sense that's an oxymoron
big-time [ __ ] submitted by a Jackie
from Taiwan
hello a man called the police on himself
wild Drive no he's like I really don't
think I should be driving there is a
juncture ever it's me
please pull me over that's kind of cool
I feel terrible why don't you just not
drive do you guys call the cops if you
see you don't try for the road yes I do
if that fool keeps getting wilder and
Wilder yup
I know rat yo pass the bottle bro I just
oh boy Joe drives by I would like to cuz
I finished it so you at 1:30 or early
bird what's California yeah yeah
everything closes and then like I would
see Joe Jeffers all the time specially
on the 10 freeway dude all the [ __ ]
Chinese kids with their nice ass cars
and which makes me feel a lot better
about about Kelowna cops in them because
I wish I was that rich drunk you're like
I'm calling anyway so just Chinese
Chinese Chinese we just drive like this
[Laughter]
watch out everybody al good luck
everybody else yeah this dude he's from
Florida his name is Michael I'm gonna
play for you it's call 911 audio this is
what do you look like when you got
arrested whoa
yeah a mess sores he admitted to
drinking and to swallowing meth he said
it's all of it and shaving what the [ __ ]
a potato peeler ok what is it driving
right now yeah ok the partner right now
it is red County Sheriff's Office we
dispatched for winning even and we have
a unit coming out to you now what is
your last name your last name sir I
think I'm gonna go get somebody else
catch up with me actually what is your
last name yeah you're driving on the
wrong side of their work going on which
direction officers are looking for you
right now I need you to pull over right
now good job
this was edited for time like this
conversation was a lot longer and then
it sounded like he was hitting like
those those plastic ball
you felt to hear the sirens in the
background
so funny how we got increasingly sassier
you tell me let's see what is your last
name
no upstanding so where did all the meth
face cars go yeah I thought those things
just keep like what are they called
speed tracks right speed I think there's
a name for track marks on their arms no
there's a name for them again actually
more like a street name no there's
actually like a street slang like it's
called speed speed something speed sores
speed bumps speed bumps I think it's
called speed I think so let's move on
let's talk about ass ass so I think a
good person or Z a bad person because
it's like saying I like Hitler because
Hallie's he killed Hitler mm-hmm Oh
cause he committed to us exactly so it's
like saying like well I like him cuz he
called because of a driver
everyone has grateful as we can learn
about even Charles Manson he does have a
criminal history of previous DUI
aggravated battery drug possession
disorderly conduct resisting and
hit-and-run so he just knows how to
party
why did he call the cops he was just bad
[ __ ] up I think it wasn't a cry for help
I think hooking tattletale you don't
snitch yes it's like that you can
yourself he was a friend she was lonely
just wanted to talk to someone while
he's driving he also mentioned that he
had only slept for hours in the past
four days oh so he probably going insane
it may he swallowed meth instead of
smoking it Oh
or you're not supposed to swallow meth I
don't know depends on what the doctor
prescribed it's funny because the police
department posted the 9-1-1 audio and
along with the post like they wrote in
the caption in the caption is said
however in this particular instance they
were talking about while driving under
the influence of anything like it's it's
a serious crime DUI is not a laughing
matter but in this particular incident
nobody was hurt so we couldn't help but
el OTO which means last hour teasers off
police job there's a bunch of [ __ ]
dead than that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that's weird because he still committed
the crime
just cuz no God but people be pulled
over for DUI all the time oh yeah I mean
he did he got a DUI okay okay I need
Rome on the opposite side of the road
I'm really glad that he called though I
wish more people would do that you know
like I wish if you're drunk you're like
I'm on the freeway I'm drunk as [ __ ]
help me and I'm talking on my phone
while driving which is illegal my meth
spoon there is a couple of cases where
people got so high like just smoking
weed they called the cops I need help
yeah I've read that uh that went way up
in Colorado but people I crushed it like
they don't talk about that much but I
think if they smoke too much pot
Colorado they people started vomiting
like being drunk
that's : calling like freaking out or
you smoke so much weed that you puked
yeah I never did that bad I just fell
asleep
it was like but so safe and like yeah
it's safe but there is a limit to
everything you put in your body like
well for me it's cuz I don't smoke like
it was like back when I was early
twenties I smoked like once every three
years or whatever just for fun um it was
a brand new bong we're gonna xbox hard
always a bomb brand new long hits don't
[ __ ] around yeah cuz I used to I used to
I was a promo model for like glass let's
make a little brag in there Bobbo was
there just big ones okay
Oh Ripper 3000 it wasn't really nicely
with my 19-inch arms but I worked for
them and then a couple of guys were my
friends also so on top of getting bait
they really here have a ball I'm like
smoke so I gave it to my friend and I'd
like a few weeks later I was going
through a breakup my friends like come
on over take a rip I like [ __ ] over
it three thousand and they're like
within like a few minutes I'm just
sitting there staring at the TV and I'm
like I tried to change the channel and I
was trying to reach for the remote but
it smelt like it took me like three
months to grab it and then I'll be like
normal time it was such a struggle and
then I was like I don't feel good and
then I went to the I don't know I got so
high that I puked at all the sushi that
I eat and I just stared at the TV and
then I could hear them talking but I
couldn't respond they're like issue okay
and I literally just fell over on the
couch like this and slept like the whole
entire night and then I won't get thanks
more like oh [ __ ] that was really bad
I've never smoked like I've never gotten
that high before I remember when I threw
up like this in high school and I I
don't know I feel like the blood that I
smoked was laced with something so I
only took one hit and I started vomiting
and it looked like coffee ground
would you eat I'm kidding - mint oreos
oh yeah why did I eat earlier that day
because I had been drinking earlier too
and I was just I was a mess I just got
really really high
to the point where every time I close my
eyes and open it it was like time has
passed a week you see your fingernails
go in and [ __ ] and I just fell asleep I
was like I'm too high and then you wake
up and then you're still high oh wow
that's crazy
yeah or you're just laying down in the
whole world is spinning like when is a
little stop roller coaster yeah so no
like when I'm not spinning but I'm
high-speed going up and down so like I'm
closing my eyes have you know like when
you get too high and you're like please
just I want to go to sleep
you know that feeling right so I'm like
this I'm like I'm like trying to like
hide from the ghosts like in the [ __ ]
cover I'm like like this and I'm like
please go to sleep but in my [ __ ]
mind I'm like at the edge of my chair
good
you know what you're sleeping and you're
dreaming that you fall hottie Joel oh
yeah my bracelet do you just so [ __ ]
up that you're just gonna die you just
like just random seizures like no it's
like my it's like something happens in
my ear or something but I feel like I
took a flip or something you wake up
like no I'm full weight and all I never
did that shadow wait you guys are
smoking down here in SoCal wake wake up
again I really super well feel like I'm
still afraid of that happening again cuz
I was at one time it's ever happened and
then now if I were ever smoking again I
feel like little by little because I'm
afraid of reaching that point again yeah
you guys some tums or some [ __ ]
[Music]